so this is the inaugural cannabis 42.0
and if you don't know what 420 is which
is what we're hinting at it's the
cannabis holiday it's basically uh april
20th it's also a time at 4 20 p.m which
is a time to celebrate
the cannabis 42.0 is a list of some of
the most influential and successful
people in the cannabis industry and we
focused on
independently owned companies we have
cannabis cultivators we have packaging
companies we have pre-rolled joint
manufacturers and edibles companies we
also have b2b companies we have software
companies and fintech platforms we're
really looking to highlight some of the
industry's fastest growing companies
most successful most influential brands
selecting 42 companies in an industry
that made 25 billion dollars in sales
last year is no easy feat we talked to
analysts we talked to investors we
talked to entrepreneurs we took into
account what all those sources said but
we also found sales data financial
documents and investor decks to
look through each company and decide
whether or not like are there sales big
enough what's their place in the market
and then we brought all that together
and weighted each company and basically
scored each company and that's how we
brought down a list of like 150
companies down to 42.
we have a couple edibles manufacturers
on our list during the pandemic edible
sales went up 40
so one of the companies is kiva
confections which is started by a
husband wife duo in the san francisco
area and they're one of the best selling
chocolates and gummies companies in
america right now
[Music]
one of the companies on the list is ae
global founded by this guy mike forensa
they're out of miami florida and one of
their main products is a child proof box
for vape cartridges child proof
packaging is obviously very important
and vital to the the health and safety
of children but also like the longevity
of this industry right we are just
getting to a point where
you know the stigma around cannabis has
been lowered most americans think it
should be legal but what you do not want
is children to get into
edibles packages vape cartridges so ae
global's position in the industry is
really important
another standout on the list is a
software company called dutchy they're
basically the shopify of the cannabis
space and they sell pos software to
dispensaries this company was founded by
two brothers in bend oregon and they
have the highest valuation of any
software company in the industry at 3.8
billion dollars
one of the biggest issues on the
business side is cash management
cannabis is still federally illegal
which means most banks in america will
not do business with these companies
what that means is that a lot of these
dispensaries have piles of cash like
literal piles of cash and they have to
bring them to a bank that will do
business with them or the federal
reserve which ironically will take that
money one of the companies is imperial
logistics which was founded by deirdre
o'gorman and her company specializes in
cash management and has a fleet of
armored trucks and other services
so we also have a place on the list for
legacy growers and operators this guy
johnny casalli he runs huckleberry hill
farms which is in southern humboldt in
california and he started growing
cannabis when he was 15. he grew up on a
farm with his mother who taught him how
to grow weed he got into the industry
before it was legal he actually went to
prison after the cops raided his his
farm and he came out went straight and
then once california was was legalizing
medical marijuana he jumped back into
the industry and so he he's a great
example of the you know the continuation
of craft cannabis right now we are
seeing the industrialization of the
cannabis industry so grows that are
humongous but huckleberry hill farms is
the opposite of industrial they uh you
know johnny's farm only produces 700
pounds of cannabis a year which sounds
like a lot but it trust me it is not and
one of his company's claims to fame is
that willie nelson you know the famous
musician in stoner uh has a company
called willy's reserve and willie's
reserve tapped johnny to grow weed for
his
brand so an emerging trend in the
industry is beverages right now it's
tiny it's about one percent of the total
market and people write it off as
nothing right but not everybody is going
to want to smoke not everybody is going
to want to vape what beverages can do is
really be an easy introduction to
cannabis to somebody who who doesn't
imbibe one of the companies on our list
is can which is a beverage company and
they specialize in what's called a micro
dose so like 2.5 milligrams of thc you
know they are going for the new consumer
people who are either returning or
people who have never consumed before
and they also have a lot of celebrity
investors they're making waves in the
beverage space
[Music]
america has reached a tipping point
where cannabis is legal in 37 states
federal legalization is on the horizon
and companies are are making products
for people who have been smoking weed
for years to people who have never once
touched an edible what we really should
look out for is some of these companies
becoming household brands
you